the world needs the next Ironman stock
chose you he made you an Avenger this
all seems big-time I'm just a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
don't he saw something in you
he believed in you
the world needs you how's the son
Oh tight around your web shooter Walker
okay how should I get gifts Parker stock
chose you
are you going to step up or not
everywhere I go I see his face
I don't think Tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
gonna be here after he was gone
how's the food it's a little tight
around the old web-shooter Parker okay
how chef spider-man
this is mr. Beck here Mysterio clam
stock chosen we need an Avenger
mr. stark trusted me I'm not gonna let
him down let's go save the world
spider-man
I've got this
the whole world was looking for the next
I read I don't know if I can live up to
that I don't think Tony would have done
what he did if he didn't know that you
were gonna be here after he was gone we
have a job to do
you're coming with us can you give that
to MJ did you send me how much to me
you got this
starke made you an Avenger the world
needs that stock made you an Avenger the
world needs people like you who's the
family neighborhood spider-man sir
please you've been to space
these creatures destroy my world we have
to stop it here now
your friends are in trouble what are you
gonna do about it I need a suit
Wow
everywhere I go I see his face just
really miss him I miss him too I don't
think Tony would have done what he did
if he didn't know that you were gonna be
here after he was gone
you gonna be a next Iron Man now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation heads up
Nick Fury is calling you I don't really
want to talk to Nicole why because if
you don't talk to him and I have to talk
I want to talk about you sent Nick Fury
to voicemail I gotta go you do not ghost
Nick Fury dorks what's up we're just
talking about the trip oh I think MJ
really likes me first alone you're a
very difficult person to contact
spider-man
this is mr. Beck we're gonna use someone
like you on my world your world Vic is
from Earth just not ours
a snap to our home in our dimension we
have a job to do you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
for offworld captain Holmes unavailable
but the funny neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl you I really like
and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
so I feel like I'm putting my friends in
danger
the world needs next Ironman you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
here I work with spider-man do work for
spider-man I won't win spider-man not
for spider-man
[Music]